أرى أرقامًا من أولئك الذين
تم اعتقالهم نتيجة
حملة قمع الفساد ، لقد رأيت
أرقامًا تشير إلى إلغاء
قد يصل إلى مائة مليار دولار تستعيدها
الحكومة ، هل
يمكنك تأكيد هذه الأرقام التي أعتقد
أن  أعلن المدعي العام منذ
أسبوعين أنهم ينظرون في
هؤلاء المشتبه بهم الذين يشتبه في
اختلاسهم حوالي مائة مليار دولار ،
ولم يعلن المدعي العام بعد عن التسويات التي تم توقيعها ،
لكننا رأينا بعضها جاهزًا ، هل
تلقيت أموالًا في البنك.
تلقيت بعض الأموال في البنك ولكن
من غير المرجح أن تكون معظم الأصول
نقدًا كما تتخيل أنها
أصول في الأصول المحتملة للخدمات العقارية ،
لكن الأمر سيستغرق بعض
الوقت حتى يتم تصفيتها بعض الأمير
الوليد.  الكثير من
الاهتمام بما يحدث معه
لم يُشاهد منذ أن
تم اعتقاله واعتقاله بأي طريقة
نريد وضعها في أي مكان  هل يمكنك إخبارنا بما
يمكنني قوله هو بدلاً من التحدث
عن الأفراد ، أردت أن أقول أيضًا
إننا نخلق مجالًا متكافئًا
للعبة أردنا التأكد من أن
رسالة الدولة واضحة جدًا بأننا
لا نتسامح مطلقًا مع الفساد وأننا
نريد المضي قدمًا وتوضيح أن
بيئة الاستثمار حيث تكون
الجودة والسعر هي المهمة
والتي من شأنها أن تحدث فرقًا
بخلاف أي شيء آخر
، وفي هذه النقطة نعود إلى هذه
القضية هناك وأعتقد أنه سيتعين
عليك الموافقة مع الوزير  إنها طريقة تقليدية للقيام
بذلك ، حيث تقوم بتجميع الأشخاص وتحبسهم
، ثم تأخذ المال منهم ، ثم ربما تسمح لهم بالذهاب
بعد ذلك دون أن يبدو يومًا في
المحكمة ، وأعتقد أن
هناك الكثير من الطرق و  القليل من الذين أجروا
مناقشات في هذا المنتدى حول هذا الموضوع في
الواقع
كانت الحكومة تمر
بهذا على مدار العامين الماضيين ،
فقد أوضحوا تمامًا أنهم حرضوا على
أنهم جمعوا الكثير من المعلومات
ولذا فليس من المفاجئ أن يتم
السماح للأشخاص بمقابلة محاميهم كل يوم
وقد وافق الناس على تسوية
التسويات قبل المحاكمة ، وهي عملية عادية
جدًا تحدث في
ولايات قضائية أخرى